hello let's keep talking about that
rumor that zendaya is Mary Jane in
spider-man homecoming so I'm not Mary
Jane unfortunately but I am in human
which is where you're not Mary Jane okay
so the rumor percolated for a long time
and at one point a leaked call sheet
from set said she was playing a
character named Michelle now a lot of
people assumed it was just attempt to
throw us off but apparently not my
girl's name is Michelle and that's what
everybody wants to think interesting so
you're you're playing Michelle yeah and
you're gonna meet Michelle well how does
it feel to be taking all you're gonna be
in the next - how does it feel to be
taking it's incredible you know if such
a huge project for you harder or in the
place I mean who could arise okay take a
better thing to be honest true movie
like it species I if I could pick a
movie a movie spider-man so I got it
okay so why do we all think one thing
and not another is that just another
like media I mean it is what it is I
still wouldn't be totally shocked if
they're just trying to mess with us at
this point but what do you guys think
will zendaya be Mary Jane after all or
is she actually a character named
Michelle and we just need to accept it
let us know your thoughts in the
comments or let's chat about it over on
Twitter thanks for watching
you